all right guys that time of year again
it's pie season you want the iconic
comfort classic the fat the fruit the
texture the crust all of it i mean pie
has it all
we tested like a million of them i'm
kind of sick of pies but i'm not sick of
pies because even after making like 20
of them like at the end of the day i
still just want to eat pie the thing
with pie is you really have to nail the
pie crust and don't be intimidated it
seems like it's something that's going
to be difficult to work with but
honestly it's just three things fat
flour and water the thing about using
like a liquid fat like a coconut oil or
olive oil or something like that is
honestly i find it so hard to work with
just stick to butter or solid fat
so we did test shortening butter and a
combo of those two things we did a taste
test we did like a tender test and just
like an overall how was it to work with
we found that shortening does tend to
give you a little bit more on the flaky
side but it doesn't taste as good and
the combo was good it was you know a
good compromise we don't love the idea
of doing combo if it's not going to give
you like a huge change in results butter
is not only going to give you a great
flavor but a great texture and if you're
going to do all this work you want it to
taste as good as it possibly can so as
you know here at tasty we love a secret
ingredient and to do that we added a
little bit of egg yolk into our water we
found it really gives it just like that
added richness that you really really
want when you're going for kind of that
ultimate holiday pie and we're also
going to add ice water to our egg yolks
literally be taking the tablespoons of
water from a cup of ice water just to
make sure that your water is as cold as
it possibly can be this is actually the
pastry recipe that i learned in culinary
school at least it just is so good as
you know always add salt to everything
that you do including sweets because it
is a flavor enhancer we are putting in
cold cold cold cubed butter we have to
keep everything as cold as possible
always so you're going to go in and
you're not going to use your palms
you're going to use your fingertips as
much as you can because your palms are
warmer than your fingertips so you're
just really trying to take the big
chunks of butter and rub them into the
flour so we're going to coat the flour
with the butter once i'm happy and i
have all the butter is pretty well
incorporated into the flour i'm ready to
add my liquid we're going to use our
judgment here and just kind of as
quickly as we can incorporate the liquid
with the fat this is still looking
pretty dry so i'm going to go to the
drier bits of the bowl and incorporate
more of that egg yolk water mixture how
you can test that is you put some
together in your palms and if it's
stained together in a little dough ball
then you're good to go so once i'm happy
that all the liquids incorporated i
think that i have a good amount of
moisture in here dump it out onto our
clean work surface and start to bring it
together get it into like a nice ball if
you will there's no like dry flowery
bits there's nothing crumbling off of it
it's gonna be a lot easier if you make
it into a disk it's gonna be much easier
to roll it out into a circle later i'm
gonna wrap it up with cling film we're
gonna put it back in the fridge and let
it chill out for a second this is gonna
let the flour and everything relax
so the thing about pie crust is it gets
harder to work with the warmer that it
is so if your fat is getting really
really warm it's gonna be hard to roll
out and work with and what you're gonna
first do flour the surface you're going
to flour the top of the pastry dough
kind of push down on the dough starting
from the bottom to the top and shmoosh
and it just kind of spreads the dough
out before you start rolling
every now and again we're going to give
the dough a quarter turn that's just
going to help ensure that we have a nice
round dough and it's also going to make
sure that we're double checking that our
dough is not sticking to the surface
that we're working on always smush the
cracks back together whenever you see a
big one forming because it's only going
to get worse
you want to roll it out to like an
eighth of an inch roll it out way bigger
than your pan is you can put your pan
over the pie crust to make sure that you
have enough
so the easiest safest way to move it is
to roll it up on your rolling pin
here we go it's not sticking to anything
voila we don't want to stretch or tear
the dough out i'm going to lift the
edges and almost lower it down in there
and i'm going to use my knuckles to push
it into the corners and then any big
seams just kind of press them out so
you're not overlapping or anything you
want like a really clean side
so first go around and just kind of tuck
this excess under and so you have one
kind of cohesive wall to work with if
you will and now we're gonna go and
crimp so we're gonna use our knuckle of
your left hand or right hand and then
the index finger and thumb of your other
hand and just go in and pinch in
so once it's crimped we're gonna chill
it down we want it to be as cold as
humanly possible before we throw it into
a super hot oven so now that we have a
crust let's talk pumpkin filling so when
it comes to dairy when we're looking at
a lot of different recipes a lot of them
have sweetened condensed milk evaporated
milk and then some combo of fresh dairy
as well so sweetened condensed milk it's
got a ton of sugar through this like
really thick interesting product
evaporated milk is a lot thinner than it
has a little bit of sugar not nearly as
much as sweetened condensed milk but why
not just use a fresh product we
understand it a little bit more so we
decided to go with half and half we
wanted to test three different things so
we wanted to test canned pumpkin as it
is roasting the canned puree and then we
also wanted to try fresh pumpkin
when we were first testing canned
roasted we wanted to put everything in
the filling and roast it aside from the
dairies but we kind of made like a
pumpkin caramel on accident there's a
little bit more margin of error there
we actually ended up just doing the
spices in the pumpkin puree that gave us
an awesome pumpkin flavor
it kind of did the double work of not
only roasting the pumpkin puree but also
really just enhance everything that's
going into this and make it like a
really intense complex flavor which is
so good and so worth it
cool so scrape it all to one side put it
back in your bowl so we're gonna throw
in the granulated sugar the dark brown
sugar just giving us a little bit of
that molasses-y flavor give it a little
bit of vanilla for that flavor enhancer
three eggs and one egg yolk and that egg
yolks just for a little bit of extra
richness without too much extra moisture
and then just whisk this until it's
completely smooth and it's gonna be like
this really nice gorgeous custard so
what we're going to do is pre-bake the
pie shell we need to fold up a big piece
of parchment
and then we're going to throw in we just
had like some dried chickpeas that we
use these are our baking beans if you
will so kind of push them off to the
side to hold up the walls and we're good
to go you're gonna put this in about
like 400 degrees fahrenheit for about 15
20 minutes or so depending on the pie
dish that you're using and to know that
it's done pull back the sheet of
parchment with the beans inside and you
just want to make sure there's no
undercooked or like raw pastry left
so we have our pre-baked pie crust let's
pour it all in there get every little
bit it's gonna be a little bit of
bubbles and what you can try and do is
kind of carefully plop it on the table
and see if you can get any of those
bubbles
with a lot of custard pies it's pretty
common to start with a really hot oven
and then lower it down and what it's
going to do is give us like that really
instant heat to get everything started
so i know that this might seem crazy but
roasting a real whole pumpkin and making
this into your pie this is so good so
cut it up get in big chunks don't go
crazy with this all we're really trying
to do is get out the seeds in that
little pulpy bit in the middle i'm using
a little paring knife makes it really
easy to get all that stuff out get these
big chunks onto a parchment-lined baking
sheet have a little fun with it just dry
roast those suckers you know really high
heat like 400 for 15-20 minutes until
you can really smell them
again developing that flavor we're gonna
throw the flesh of the pumpkin into a
food processor with everything else that
we need the sugars the eggs the heavy
cream the vanilla the salt all the good
stuff and give it a whiz it's not going
to be as smooth and kind of like mush i
guess as the puree that comes out of a
can which is really nice actually like
it has a little bit more of a bite to it
but it's still like super creamy and
delicious honestly with the food
processor like do this more than you
think because you do want a pretty
smooth texture so once we're to a good
place pour that into your pre-baked
crust if you really want to do something
a little bit extra like these steps
don't take a ton of extra time and they
give you a very complex and very unique
take on a pumpkin pie and same deal
we're going to do a nice high heat to
start and then we're going to lower it
down to finish the cooking all right so
again like we just could not decide
between apple and pumpkin so we gave you
both guys there are tons of different
varieties of apples the only thing that
you really need to know for this one
like we're using granny smith because
they're easily accessible got a great
tart flavor they really work well in
pies but if you have different ones in
your grocery store as long as you're
using cooking apples that'll hold up to
cooking doesn't matter for apple pie we
tested three different preparations we
tested fresh apples putting in mastered
apples which just means they sat in
sugar and salt for a bit to draw out the
extra moisture and then we also tested a
cooked apple recipe we found that we
preferred the macerated method because
we had a lot of good like bites still to
the apples but since we took care of a
lot of that moisture loss we didn't have
like huge gaps in our pie you have a
little bit of a bite but they're cooked
enough that it's not like you're biting
into raw apple and as you're peeling
them it's a really good idea to have a
big bowl of water if you have some
lemons pop a little in the water too
that'll just keep them from browning so
we're going to use like so many apples
because they do have a lot of moisture
in them and they are going to bake down
core them cut them into those little
cheeks and then slice them super thinly
so we're going to masturbate these
apples and what we're going to do is put
salt and sugar which are both desiccants
and that's just a fancy way of saying
that they draw out moisture from what
they come in contact with and the salt
is not only going to draw out moisture
but it's also going to help enhance the
flavors that are in there i'm going to
put in cinnamon here a little bit of
lemon juice so what we're just adding
aside from the dust cans are just a
little bit of flavor that'll just kind
of marinate a little bit we're also
going to add half of our cornstarch now
so we're going to toss all the apples
and all this stuff and we're actually
going to let it sit for about 30 minutes
it's a good idea to stir every like 10
minutes or so just so the apples on the
top or in the middle can really drain
out all that extra moisture
after that 30 minutes we're going to let
it sit in a colander over another bowl
and we're actually going to just draw
out all that liquid so we really want to
make sure that we're getting out as much
moisture from these apples as we can
right now
so as you can see i mean look at all
this moisture that came out of these
apples like holy moly so we're gonna
boil this down there is a bit of
cornstarch so this mixture should
thicken up a good amount right away so
we're gonna take the rest of that
cornstarch add a few tablespoons of
water to make a slurry so we don't have
like big chunks of cornstarch and we're
gonna throw our slurry in here and just
thicken this up we don't want to boil it
too much but we're gonna add a little
knob of butter there so it's gonna stop
the cooking process a little bit so it
doesn't boil too much it's also gonna
give us a little bit of that extra that
extra flavor and silkiness once that
butter is pretty much melted in we're
going to take it off heat we want to be
kind of the texture of caramel if you
can see here so it looks like a nice
thick caramel so coat all the apples of
this mixture once that's all done we're
ready to build our pie we're going to
roll out a sheet of dough same as before
nothing fancy with the apple pie we're
actually not going to pre-bake it
because it does need a good amount of
time in the oven you don't have to be
like super crazy with laying the apples
in here but you do want to make sure
they're all flat and if you can have
them be the round side out again just so
that we can pack all the apples in here
so every now and then push them down
this is a lot of apples we want to
totally pack this guy full and if
there's any extra of that like kind of
caramelly filling in there go ahead and
pour it on top of the apples you
shouldn't have a ton left over and we're
going to put a new sheet of pastry on
top of it cut off the excess
so we're going to make sure that we have
a really secure seal between the top and
the bottom layers so pinch and fold
pinch and fold and before you even worry
about decorating the sides you want to
make sure that's really tight and sealed
do the knuckle finger all the way around
and then go ahead and do an egg wash
again we're just going to use straight
up egg here and then for a little extra
crunch we're going to add this standing
sugar and that's just going to give us a
nice texture
fruit pies and apple especially has a
lot of moisture in there so we want to
cut little holes so that the steam can
get out so we don't have our pie like
literally explode when it's baking and
into the oven it goes
wow look how nice that is
the food stylist trick is to cut a
little sliver out first and don't worry
about this one it's going to be ugly so
that you don't end up messing up the
whole pie you can get really nice slices
i know it's like a lot to do and there's
these little tips and things there but
like if you're not gonna do it around
the holidays and around thanksgiving
like when are you gonna do it
look at that i mean isn't it just so
cool the fact that it just has so much
like oomph to it you know
so whether you're a custard fan or a
fruit pie person we've got two different
really awesome pies here they're not too
over the top they're relatively simple
they're definite crowd pleasers go make
this pie do it for yourself do it for
the ones you love be the champion of
this year's thanksgiving and bring the
pie
insert pie pun yeah that's what we need
what's a pie pun you want a piece of me
i only have pies for you
be the apple of my pie yeah give us your
best pie pun
you